a liberal democracy is always going to
have Golems it's always going to have
these these kind of political tribes or
religious tribes or whatever and the the
thing that it makes a liberal democracy
special isn't that it has it gets rid of
these it's that it
has an immune system to keep them from
taking over and what's happened I think
in the last
decade few decades but especially in the
most recent decades maybe due to social
media and and a few other things people
have gotten too very very scared of
these Golems they've become scarier you
know and that has turned into the immune
the people stopping standing up for
Liberal values and going quiet
and that's the immune system failing
that's that's you know when you scale up
a bunch of scared individuals you get a
in a mass skill you get this immune
system failing and these Golems kind of
like Godzilla tramping through Society
in a way that they really couldn't do in
the older days you know they this is
this is pretty new
[Music]
foreign
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the author of the new book
what's our problem you know him as
weight but why Tim Urban welcome Tim
thank you very much this is a cool place
to record I like this well first
congratulations on being a new Papa
you've got like a one month old which is
a lot uh it's your first I know yeah
it's um she's three weeks today
and uh she doesn't and you have not
slept in three weeks no and she and she
yeah so so first of all I'm not going to
be able to get a sentence out first of
all but second of all she doesn't um
yeah she doesn't provide any positive
feedback
she goes from like if there's one
through ten right and 10 is like you're
really happy and one is you're really
sad she goes from a one to a five so if
she gets to neutral I'm like dude all it
is as long as you're not yelling or
crying at me like it's all to the good
and they're just like looking around
then that's the looking around is the
the promise line I mean and then when
she's crying
and I'm like okay I've done the
checklist I've done that I'm like still
crying and now I'm like I now and then
the the contradictory advice like I'll
be like oh I wish I'll rock her and
they're like don't rock her to sleep and
I'm like well then I'll put her down
like don't leave her crying I'm like I
don't I don't know you know that there's
a parenting
um resource that I I liked a lot um do
you know who Emily Oster is yes anyway
her stuff read that book okay cool
you're on it you're on it it's all the
good yeah I don't know people who are
like very like anti-reading the books
I'm like I'll read all the books and get
all the advice
but I will say that um the the
contradictory advice is really like that
that's the painful part for sure I'll
give you the best advice just listen to
Mom
listen to your wife I'm not sure she
knows what to do right now either but I
just went down to listen to your wife
path and we're still married and you
know two kids later
so you have this very very prominent
successful blog that's a combination of
cartoons and illustration and very very
deeply detailed blog posts first
congrats on that because that's how I
first found out about it thank you uh so
how did you wind up going down this path
and and how did it develop yeah I um I I
was blogging on the side and like for my
whole 20s on this like little random
blog um and then you know this is like
getting to be around 30 and I was like I
need to go full time on some things I
was doing a lot of things and I you know
decided blogging uh was a decent
um was it was a good was a good choice
um I uh I was working with a friend
Andrew Finn and we were like
trying to we were doing this business
together and then I was like vlogging
and I was like What if I just go and go
full time on this pretty wild when the
blog overtakes the business man that's a
pretty good blog yeah well which
it is by the way and like I'd urge
anyone to check out wait but why I I
mean I think the lesson is like for me
is don't worry too much about like the
specific
thing that you're working on as much as
whether it is something that you you
really are excited about because
um we had a pretty cool business I just
was not my heart wasn't in it because it
wasn't what I really wanted to be doing
and so I put out such a Better Effort
when I started writing full-time because
it was something I actually was excited
about and so I just did like a a way
better job like a way better version of
me was suddenly doing this thing and um
it's profound yeah when when you're
actually calling on 100 of yourself uh
powerful things can happen much more
frequently than when you're calling on
some less than 100 of yourself yeah
yeah you know it's it's it's really a
thing and even just like you know when
you're it's like the if you're if you're
if you're fully in on something then
like when you're in the shower you're
thinking about it when you wake up in
the morning you you've been you know
your mind's been working on it while
you're sleeping and
um and you're just kind of percolating
on it all the time because you're really
excited about it you're actually really
interested in it you're not feeling like
oh finished work can check out
integrated self my friend it's a
beautiful thing you actually think about
it when you don't have to think about it
right yeah that's and and then of course
more of your mind is going to be working
on it so yeah so this book aptly named
what's our problem
um you started thinking about this uh
like a a while ago and the book took
some time to come together yeah sometime
for sure
um you said your kids are seven and ten
yeah yeah so they were like one and four
I don't know you can remember what that
was like that that that's when I was
um I started thinking about this topic
so I yeah basically it was like mid 2016
and Trump hadn't even won yet he hadn't
even been nominated yet and this was
like in the it was it was heating up the
primaries it was yes it was Trump
Madness on one side
um but then there was like I was also
looking at like I don't know if you
remember this video came out
um I think Greg lucianov took this video
actually it was um uh at Yale and there
was this this whole uh debacle over like
Halloween costumes whatever it was this
viral YouTube video of students
screaming at Nick christakis about how
this should be a safe space
um not an intellectual space I do
remember this episode and I remember
thinking it's it's so they so a safe
space is in conflict with an
intellectual space is what I took from
that video and and and I said that's
something that's that's what's up with
that and and when I and I started this
was part of it was kind of this last
straw for me because something had been
building up which was like
I think like nothing in 2012 I remember
thinking that like nothing was simpler
than
like
you know there was it was foreign policy
issues and there's domestic policy
issues I don't know what I think about
any of these it's like so complicated
but I was like social issues those are
easy like gay marriage obviously that's
a good thing right like that it felt so
good I was like I can have conviction
about something political like yes like
social justice issues right it was just
like so clear that like the left is on
the right side there and like if if I
don't know what I think about anything
else
these have to be my guys because of how
that how the social issues right versus
in 2012 you have like Rick Santorum and
all these super you know
anti-anti gay marriage and other
whatever and and it was so now flash
four years later and I'm thinking like
I I'm feeling like very
um kind of scared of the social justice
people and I don't want to write about
it this is something I normally would be
so proud I was like I'm scared to touch
it and I'm like what's going on there so
it was this issues then you also had the
Trump going on I said
I write a lot about AI I write a lot
about Green Machine interfaces and VR
and all this cool stuff in the future I
said none of that's gonna matter if
we're like if something bad's going on
in our like underlying workings of our
society yeah I I agree with that and so
that was like the beginning of me
working on this well so AI is getting
smarter and we are getting Dumber I mean
it's a pretty bad combo yeah it's not
great it's not great our technology in
general is
exponentially getting more powerful well
our friend Tristan Harris says we have
primordial brains medieval institutions
and god-like Technologies yeah yeah it's
a pretty nasty cocktail so your book and
I want to dig into it I'd be brandishing
a copy but at present it is digital only
and audio only did you record it
yourself
I did which was grueling people don't
know how hard it is to read your own
book so hard I mean also I just like
there's it's a skill and the people who
do it all the time they're professionals
I'm an amateur I was like I don't have
this skill so I'm messing up every
sentence and I'm like how many days did
it take you so it was uh nine five hour
days so 4 45 hours to record a 14-hour
audio understood way to spread that out
man because your your voice actually
gets tired well I I probably wouldn't
have but the studio themselves are like
five hours is the max because they know
that you get fatigued and yeah yeah your
brain gets tired and you actually start
messing up more too towards the end of
the session so in your book you talk
about there being something of a ladder
of thinking which I enjoyed a great deal
uh and I can let you dig into the the
four levels the highest level is
scientists what entertained me was that
the next level was
um I believe sports fan uh and then the
level below that was attorney which
you're like wait like sports fans are
smarter than attorneys I'm getting a lot
of trouble for this I've gotten some
very angry attorneys um I'm not talking
about actual scientists sports fans
attorneys I'm talking about each of
these is representing a certain like
way of thinking a certain goal and
um so when I talk about scientists first
of all so so the the premise of here is
that this is a vertical ladder vertical
axis
um we talked so much about Left Right
Center in politics right
um and like when you know we talk about
when I hear forward party I don't see
Center as much it is Center horizontally
but what I see is actually something
that is we're trying to introduce the
third dimension like we they're actually
people in Ford who are like no no avoid
the Centrist thing though it does work
out like that right a lot because but
um the the fact is there are people who
are part of forward who are Libertarians
or people are forward who are like
considered essentially like far lefties
yeah well and the point is if if all you
have is one axis and you're trying to
say Hey you know we're so polarized we
need more people on the center
what comes along with that is the
assumption that if you have a far left
view for example you're you know you
believe in socialism
um uh and um or you you you you know you
think there's a real deep underlying
systemic racism whatever it's an
assumption that that person must be
tribal and and non-thinking and right
and that's not necessarily true actually
and likewise it's also assuming that if
you have views in the center if you
happen to have you something that means
you're a great thinker that's not
necessarily true either I know a lot of
people who are Centrist in their reviews
but they're super dogmatic and they're
actually dogmatic about being Centrist
and so if you make it a square and now
you have this other axis it frees that
up so now it's like
um you can have people across the
horizontal Spectrum up high and down low
so the fact that you've introduced this
second dimension of politics I think is
so invaluable and what what you've done
is you introduced four levels of
thinking so uh scientists I think people
instinctively can imagine what that is
it's like hey let's see what the effects
and the data say and then uh sports fan
uh then the level below that is attorney
which is you're just arguing for a side
and you're not even trying to so the way
I think about it is and then I also want
to say the fourth level just so that
there's something below attorney is
zealous which we all kind of uh
recognize now it really is stems from
there's two
motivations that you could have when
you're trying to come up with your
beliefs there's two ways to form beliefs
right
um one and I think this is a character
in our brain is just one's truth is is
humble it doesn't think doesn't identify
with ideas like list if my idea is wrong
tell me and I'll change it let's let's
get closer to the truth right it seems
very rational and then the other way is
totally different and this is this kind
of primitive software in our head who
identifies with ideas and and that goal
is to confirm the ideas you already
believe and to keep believing them and
to make sure that that anyone you know
you get you hate anyone who disagrees
with you on them and and you don't like
to argue very much because or you might
like to argue you'll never change your
mind because changing your mind is an
existential crisis when you're in that
mode so we both have we all have both of
these and the latter to me is about when
you're on that top rung it's that
rational what I would call a higher mind
um that cares about truth is fully
running the show so you just or you're
thinking like that you just are looking
for Truth Now actual career scientists
are often not like this by the way this
is not even praising career scientists
this is thinking like a scientist like
the perfect scientist
and then when you go down to the sports
fan rung of the ladder you're still
that's a second one so you're still a
little the truth character in your head
is still has the edge but there's this
new uh there's this other
um ulterior kind of motive where now a
little part of you really root are you
sports fan because it's like the sports
fan doesn't want corrupt refs they still
want the game played fairly they care
about truth in the end they want to know
who really was better who really won but
they're rooting they're rooting so
they're they're they're they're they
have confirmation bias and this is so
this is what you know it's like you
still you still care about truth but
there's a lot of confirmation bias
infecting your thinking process Tom
Brady didn't deflate those footballs
yeah I actually used that example
because I'm from Newton Mass and I was I
I There is almost nothing you could have
told me back then that would have gotten
me to say you know I don't think the
Patriots earn their Super Bowls I mean
the amount of confirmation bias
um and I still think they earned all
their Super Bowls by the way um but but
the tribalism is very powerful too but
if someone said you know Hey listen you
can if you can press this button and the
refs are going to rig the Super Bowl in
favor of the Patriots I wouldn't have
done that and I don't think most sports
fans would you don't yeah I mean the
point it's it's that you still it's not
fun if you win by cheating you still
want your team to win fair and square so
it's this nuanced thing and the attorney
is the rung below and the difference
between the attorney and the sports fan
both of them are in the middle so they
both have both of these motives going on
but the attorney in the end let's have a
switchboard that I want my team to win
yeah yeah you you will you won't change
your mind in the end you care more about
being right than getting it right then
care more about being right than the
truth deep down and and you know that
because that person will argue and
they'll come up with all this evidence
because they still understand there's a
truth funding process but they're a
brick wall you will never actually
change their mind and so the reason I
use attorney for this real world
attorneys are part of a two
attorney system and they know that the
best way for the system to find truth is
for them to make the best possible case
for one side of the argument because
they know the other person the other
attorney is doing the same on the other
side so that the clash of the two the
jury can see the truth right so they can
still be a truth caring person as an
attorney but they know their job is to
do this now if the problem when you're
thinking like an attorney is you only
have one attorney in your head you don't
have the whole the both sides so you're
basically instead of trying to find the
truth you'll build a case in your head
for why you're correct and and it's not
that hard to do if you want to if you
want to confirm any belief you can find
evidence seeming that seems like it's
evidence out there for it and then
finally get to the Zealot rung and now
it's the the part of your brain that
wants to confirm your ideas is entirely
running for the show there's no elements
of truth it's like you know you're right
you don't even need evidence you don't
even need to argue because the sky is
blue you don't need evidence that the
sky is blowing you actually the person
arguing against you is clearly a bad
person not yet there are terrible
exactly and at the top someone who you
disagree with is is they're interesting
why do you disagree maybe they're wrong
but as you go down and go it goes from
wrong to stupid to evil to bad evil
person if they disagree with me and
you're not you're so out of your mind
when you're in that Zone by the way
we've all been there I've been there
like when you're in that zone and you
think that anyone who disagrees with you
is a deeply bad person you've gotten
totally sucked into human craziness
you're not You've Lost Your Truth
finding capabilities in that moment
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
oh yeah it's one of the noxious elements
of this time which I'm sure you've
experienced uh which is that like some
people will attack you and then it will
naturally make you want to move in
opposition to whatever the heck they're
standing for you're like what what are
you coming after me for it's like what
are you into then I'm like I'm just stop
being about ideas it's now about
tribalism this person is is the out
group I hate this person and so suddenly
like this whole other part of your brain
that's very ancient kind of wakes up and
is like they're the out the bad guys and
I'm the good guy so and which by the way
is one of the the
um more Sinister elements of this
two-sided system we have because there
are a lot of people that I think are
naturally kind of like want to hang out
uh uh you know in the scientist zone or
like in the middle and don't want to
regret people's evil but then when they
get cast in a particular way then they
end up getting pushed to one side or the
other and the media doesn't help the
media is a huge part of it the media
just like pillory is a certain person
and then you're like wait a minute I
guess I'm over here then because these
people don't and they're going to show
you if you're watching you know your
your media and didn't used to have my
Medias to have you know everyone's media
now it's like you know every the tribe
has their own media it's going to
present the worst kind of people on the
other side it's gonna make you seem it's
going to demonize people that there was
a study that just came out that Marjorie
Taylor green gets like 10 times the
Press of any of like a reasonable
number you said this I think it was like
in the early 80s he said you got to give
them conflict if you give them conflict
you get attention I mean he knew a long
time ago and it's still the case I mean
look how much attention Trump got they
meet the the you know the it's the
left-wing media helped him get elected
they were huge for him in 2016 then
Trump wins uh and then your book ends up
I'm sure morphing that's it's a problem
I never want to write about current
events again because every time
something happens you're like well let's
just change the story I had to go and
incorporate this so yeah I mean to have
the whole Arc of the rise of trump the
beginning of the book the whole Arc to
pass January 6th by the end of the book
um is I mean even past the 2022 midterms
where you know the a lot of the election
deniers were candidates um so that whole
Arc happened yeah in the process and
also just the whole kind of woke Arc
happened it was very new if you said
wokeness back in when I started this no
one had heard that term even social
justice Warrior which was like a
pejorative before wokeness came as a
thing even that wasn't a term yet at the
time that's how early it was and then to
have that whole Arc and everything that
happened there and so it was fascinating
to watch but also stressful because I'm
like I have to the book is now obsolete
again it kept on growing and growing so
um I love this second dimension this
high low and so you use these fun
metaphors of genies and gollums where
you you had uh or originally in the you
know better version of politics you had
people arguing for their version
um in terms of facts and policies and
then the other people on the other side
um but then unfortunately we've gotten
now brought down a couple of levels
where it's become more tribalistic and
less reasoning
um and you characterize essentially like
the the gollum on each side as
unfortunately so certainly and I'm going
to say on the Republican side uh like
the nastier more
unreasoning elements of taking hold of
the party with the rise of trump but
then you say that there is a version on
the other side too and you referenced it
a little bit when you talked about
what's going on on campuses yeah I think
um I think that the it's not that
politics should be people being nice and
agreeing like when I think of high rung
politics
it's heated it's passionate right those
people protesting there's there's
vigorous debate they might not like each
other but they're in the end they're
fighting about ideas and the underlying
thing that unites everyone up there
whether they disagree or agree is this
common goal of a better country and the
it's like two lawyers in a courtroom
their Clash
moves the country forward right it's
like this it's like this positive sum
game
when you go to the low rung politics
which I sometimes like to call political
Disney World because it's Disney you
know it's the land of good guys and evil
villains right and and it it's um the
mindset is not let's make a better
country together even though that's what
maybe people think it is that's not
what's going on it's let's defeat the
bad guys we're the good right we're
perfectly righteous we have no flaws and
they're evil and demonic and let's
defeat the bad guys and if only we had
it our way the country would be perfect
but there you know whatever it's this
very Us Versus Them concept
that's a zero-sum game
that moves the country backwards when
their Clash hurts the whole country
where while The Clash on high rung
politics pushes forward exactly so they
were both clashes again these were both
heated as a subtle difference sometimes
but one is arguing about ideas and
they're experimenting and and it's not
about it's not like an ethnic
tension-like type thing it's not like a
um you know evil and good it's it's like
we're all here trying to do the same
thing I think you're wrong but let's
discuss it and at the bottom it is it's
this war of not ideas but it's a war of
peoples it's it's it gets into the same
kind of thing that creates religious
words versus zealots I mean they can get
very very dangerous yeah and and by the
way when you're in that environment you
feel a lot of pressure from your own
side to any kind of you know
legitimizing the other side you'll feel
it from your own side it's each side
kind of bullies themselves into staying
that way there's a lot of Conformity
pressure it's it's not it's not it's
different cultures if it's when you're
down there it's not cool to say I don't
know what I think about this policy
because that makes you seem like a
wishy-washy you know callous whatever
um and it's not cool too uh say maybe
they have a point right on the top and
the higher higher rung culture it's
actually very cool to say I don't know
it makes you look like you have some
humility and it it's it's actually um
speaking with unearned conviction up
there makes you seem stupid well on the
bottom you know on the low right it's
all honored conviction exactly and the
more conviction you speak with about how
good we are and how bad they are the
smarter and better you seem as a person
well certainly social media uh helps
it's one reason why I love what you've
done so much is that you've managed to
build a massive social media presence
based upon insight and reason and
learning whereas a lot of social media
is about hey if I if I'm angry and loud
and uh and you you document the Dynamics
of social media is like if you find a
villain and then rally people to defeat
the villain that's how you get energy
but both of us have learned I think just
on social media is there's a giant
audience of people who uh really don't
like political tribalism they think it's
lame they think it's boring they think
it's harmful they think it's whatever I
mean
um and actually if you look at any
survey I mean that is the majority of
the country and that that that group
spans the political axis there are
people on the far right far left and
everything in between Queen in that
group of people who don't want to be in
political Disney World but on you know
there's some crazy stats that's the
opposite of Disney World so it's
political Disney World political Disney
World is like you know and then I just
call it high rung politics it's a bunch
of grown-ups acting like grown-ups these
grown-ups again they don't like each
other all the time and they have Furious
disagreements and they passionately care
about what they they care about but
they're not
living in a this Disney fictional movie
uh which is crazy for grown-ups to be so
how did the Golems take control and and
you write about this in the book where
like there were different processes
where you know like that you had the
right wing Golem uh yeah rise to power I
think Gingrich had a lot to do with it
well so so yeah the the I used the term
Gollum for like it's like the emergent
property of like low rung political
group like it's an echo chamber which a
bunch of people right who are scared to
disagree with each other but there's an
emergent thing there think of this big
dumb giant then I call a Golem that like
runs you know tramps like Godzilla
through a society
a liberal democracy is always going to
have Golems it's always going to have
these these kind of political tribes or
religious tribes or whatever
um and the the thing that it makes a
liberal democracy special isn't that it
has it gets rid of these it's that it
has an immune system to keep them from
taking over so there's a I think of it
as kind of the liberal immune system
um and the lit you know the or the high
rung immune system and what it what
that's made of is kind of um a very
proud culture of like how we do things
here and there's a Live and Let Live
Concept in a place like the US and it's
like regardless of what you you know
believe or who you are like Live and Let
Live as long as you're not harming
someone else do your thing and and and
let other people live right and that's
how a Golem thinks they they go they go
their goal of the Golem is to
um to enforce its ways on everyone but
again the immune system is people who
will stand up against that so first of
all the law doesn't let them use
physical Force so that's a huge
disadvantage that most in other
countries at golemick can actually
execute you and things like that and
then without physical force all they
have is you know build an ability to
socially bully people and culturally
control and so the liberal immune system
is people who say that's not how we do
things here and we'll push back on them
and what's happened I think in the last
decade few decades but especially in
most recent decades maybe due to social
media and and a few other things people
have gotten too very very scared of
these Golems they've become scarier you
know and that has turned into the immune
the people stopping standing up for
Liberal values and going quiet
and that's the immune system failing
that's that's you know when you scale up
a bunch of scared individuals you get a
in a mass skill you get this immune
system failing and these Golems kind of
like Godzilla tramping through Society
in a way that they really couldn't do in
the older days you know they this is
this is pretty new
thank you
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
so the the biggest example in recent
times of folks trying to stand up to the
Golem in my opinion
uh of their own party uh was
Republican members of Congress voting to
impeach Trump uh where you had 10
Republican members uh raise their hands
and say yeah like that like we should
impeach Trump over
um Dan sex and
uh uh I think it was maybe
um half a dozen or so maybe seven uh
Republican Senators did the same
um and by the way that number of
Republican house members was
significantly greater than 10 in the
minutes before the vote
um but what happened was each of their
phones blew up with death threats yeah
and uh people saying uh you know hey if
you do this your career's over your life
is over like we're gonna come get you
and so as the vote was being passed
around there were different people who'd
said they were going to vote Yes that
voted no and then the other people are
going to vote us like oh wait a minute
you were a yes a minute ago and it's
like what am I going to do and my
phone's blowing up so the 10 members of
Congress including people like Adam
kinzinger and Liz Cheney Peter Meyer uh
something I had to go into hiding
afterwards because you vote uh you know
I mean so when you talk about like hey
physical violence is theoretically off
the table I mean now that's
unfortunately become a very potent uh
threat and reality
um in in some quarters but those 10
Republican house members eight of them
didn't make it back to the house so
there's there was like this massive
punishment exacted on most all of them
uh it's I mean it it when you talk about
Classical liberalism being like the the
check on the low rung politics I mean
like the lowering politics have gotten
more and more threatening and potent
certainly on the Republican side yeah I
mean it's it it's like you just
described a story of like an immune
system trying to kick in yeah and word
off a threat and then
the threat basically
reaching that immune system and and it
finally it's
it's it's kind of a game of like courage
and cowardice and integrity versus
trying to be popular right I mean it's
in and um by the way I want to throw in
too uh there was only one Republican
senator who voted to impeach Trump who
was on the ballot in November and that
was Lisa murkowski of Alaska so Trump
then endorsed a challenger but Lisa
murkowski made it back through why
because there was no Republican primary
in Alaska it was just anyone could vote
for anyone if there had been a
Republican primary Lisa murkowski loses
to uh Kelly Shabaka hands down because
she was very on like you know the like
Trump was there being like hey let's ask
Lisa but there was no primary so that
everyone could vote for everyone and
there were enough folks who still liked
Lisa among the general population it's
very mafia-esque it's like you know if
you're on if if you wrong us
we will assassinate your career yeah
right it's very mafia-esque and in a way
that again is not really what you want
U.S politics to be it's very much not
what you want especially if someone's
going to try and be the immune system
um and so one of the things we're trying
to do with forward is like look how does
the mafia enforce itself so
um powerfully It's like because they
don't have to enforce themselves even
among 50 of the population they just
have to enforce it among like the 10 to
12 in the base that vote in the primary
so if you can turn off the um the
primaries then more folks like Lisa
murkowski by the way in my opinion like
was her vote influenced by the fact that
she knew she had no Republican primary
probably you know so she could have a
little more courage yeah you have more
courage because it's like I don't have
to like you know I don't have to go
through just like the gauntlet of like
10 to 12 like I can just go straight to
the entire public
yeah I think I think it's like an
interesting metric to like another way
you can break down a human is their
inner self which is what they're
thinking and their outer self which is
what they're saying right and in a
healthy
environment of any kind
you have those two things match right
people are saying what they think and
when there's a situation when a lot of
people are thinking something that no
one's saying or a lot of people are
saying something that No One Believes
you have to say what's going on here
because something there's some external
Force which is making people terrified
to to reveal what they're really
thinking terrified to be themselves
terrified to have integrity openly and
um and so what is that thing and and
that's never going to be good for the
country right it's never going to be
good for any environment it's not good
for a science academy if everyone's
scared to research to certain things
they'll get in trouble it's not good for
a classroom if everyone's scared to have
this Viewpoint or a debate if no one
will take this side it's not nothing
good comes to this right you want people
to be you know feel safe to open up so
what we're talking about here the fact
that she's so rare right is
um is is an example you know that a lot
of a lot of other people who thought the
same thing yeah totally this is the
party of Reagan Reagan listen to any
speech of his it is not just different
than Trump it's the polar opposite and
again this is why we need this access
that's vertical axis because people like
to say oh the Republican Party the
Republican party has moved farther and
farther right and maybe but like I know
it's moved lower and lower yes Trump is
not a right-wing person compared to
Reagan right Reagan was ideological
Trump is all over the place and he has a
lot of modern reviews what he is he's
much lower rung which means he's much
more tribal and divisive and and he'll
lie he doesn't care about truth
um and he'll do Mafia like coercion
right as opposed to you know Reagan
wasn't like that he spoke if you listen
to his speeches he talks about if you
love your country you have to love your
countrymen and he he talked about how um
the doors will always be open to people
all around the world right and Trump is
doing the exact opposite build the wall
and polar opposite all right check it
out then check it out so so I think most
people can sense the regression to lower
rung politics in the Republican side and
the immune system is broken down which
by the way like I'm just like hey guys
because I see people all the time who
are like you know trying to restore the
Republican party and I'm like look I
wish you luck
I'm not seeing it
um so how can one try to uh reverse that
process like if it's gone from high
wrong Reagan to low-rung Trump and then
this like Mafia enforcement like is
there a path back
or how do you get the immune system well
I think you have to look at how it it's
already been down what what what's
what's been pulling it down right and I
think it does have to do with something
like Fox News
um which is a giant mega church which is
very much like training people on the
Disney narrative you know each each
party has their Disney narrative about
why we're the perfect righteous things
and they're evil so this is a big mega
church with preachers you know
um Rush Limbaugh back in in his day and
um you know
um Dr Carlson whoever you want to say
these are these are charismatic
preachers on them all right and um and
that didn't used to be like that that
started in 1996 Fox News right yeah
Arthur Brooks thinks that uh cable
Talking Heads have become the new
preachers and taking the place of what
religion used to be yeah no absolutely
it's very religious all this and again
on the left you see but a lot of Zella
treaty and
um and so you have that you also have
social media yeah which is a whole new
thing I mean that's a that's you know I
think so so the same exact Human Nature
we don't you know human nature hasn't
changed in thousands of years the same
human nature created the Nazis created
the Roman Empire created you know Greek
philosophy created medieval you know
witch burnings right and created liberal
democracies it's all the same people the
same human nature we're not better
people what the difference is you create
one environment and the human nature
goes in and behavior comes out you
change that environment the same nature
goes in different Behavior comes out
different a different system comes out
and so when you look at something like
why when you look at these giant
environmental shifts like
Fox News you know and just tribal media
in general and social media and things
like the foreign threat going away you
know back in the 60s and 70s people were
scared of the Soviet Union before that
of Hitler
um
that's kind of gone right the parties
used to be a mixed you know
that was the source of a simmering
Source now the ideological you know
purification of the party so these are
all environmental shifts I don't think
there's any evil people here I think
that you look at these shifts and you
say well it's it's yielding this result
um and so if you want to think about how
that can go back in the other direction
I think you have to you know it's not
that you're going to undo these shifts
you're not going to go back to the
environment of the 60s or the 50s
but okay how can we work with what we do
have and evolve it and you know kind of
shape it into a way that's going to
produce better Behavior because again
the the exhaustive majority is not in
favor of this stuff so that's the hard
part if you had to change everyone's
mind that would be hard it's actually
the minds many of them are already
changed here or are already in the right
place it's like you have to empower it's
this fear of of speaking out this silent
majority has to not be silent or you
know so uh so what we're trying to do is
turn off the party primaries which would
then uh amplify the voice of the silent
majority that's an environmental change
that's an environmental change yeah it's
huge it could be it could be one of
those things that is you know one reason
why I appreciate what you're doing is uh
you know you're You're Building uh media
organization that uh is speaking about
facts and truth and uh reason and trying
to elevate people's thinking so you have
this degeneration to low-run politics in
the Republican side
um but there there is a Golem on the
other side oh yeah and and you talk
about your own personal Arc which I'm
going to suggest I'm just going to speak
for myself because I'm not going to
speak for you but like I went to school
in New England at Brown University uh
and uh was a Democrat
um for really like you know my entire
sentient adulthood like without
questioning it too hard I mean I was
like I went to Brown I come to New York
New York's obviously like a very very
blue town but then there has been this
relatively recent set of development
where
um you talk about Classical liberalism
and reason there there has been
um like a new zealotry uh on the left
yeah um and I think that just because
someone's self labels a group
self-labels is something doesn't mean
that's what they are so if you you know
the zealotry I'm talking about I like to
call it social justice fundamentalism
which is I think wokeness is just a term
loaded with baggage and it's often used
by right-wing provocateurs and whatever
social justice fundamentalism which I
Define pretty clearly in the book which
is which is completely different than
liberal social justice liberal social
justice
is what it's liberal which means it it
it it wants to make the country more
liberal not less it looks at things like
um you know he wants to make sure free
speech is it's always fighting for free
speech and it wants to use the tools of
liberalism to fix the to improve the
flaws and and to and to fix the things
that are illiberal so you know like you
know blacks have to ride in the back of
the bus that is not meeting the promises
of the country so let's use the tools of
liberalism like protest and free speech
and free assembly to and voting to um to
change that right social justice
fundamentalism is fundamentally it's it
it's anti-liberal um and that's not
necessarily bad in itself it's not that
I think that you know we've we've the
discussion on this is over and
liberalism is purely good it's one
philosophy but it's it's um but it it
it's tactics are illiberal
um and it it is so I think what people
who don't look hard enough they think
you know what they would call wokeness
is just a really radical version of
social justice it's the modern version
of the civil rights movement and that's
just not true what it is is it is is it
is fundamentally opposed to Liberal
social justice it is something that says
we're not going to take the liberal
tools of the country to make it better
it's Audrey Lord's metaphor you can't
use the Master's tools to fix the
Master's house I think is what it is
um and it wants to fundamentally it it
is it thinks that the the the nuts and
bolts of the society the actual founding
promise is bad but again that's just a
philosophy I don't happen to agree with
it but that's fine the the issue I take
is that it doesn't you know it's you're
supposed to in the U.S if you want to
change things use persuasion get out
there and protest write op-eds uh do
speeches you know whatever you want get
out there and and change people's and
that's how so many of the most biggest
seismic things happen you're talking
about look it's fine for you to compete
in the marketplace of ideas but like
that that doesn't seem to be the
Tactical approach well think I think of
it as like boxing right a boxing match
and the people the things and the boxing
that the boxers aren't people their
ideas so take the Civil Rights move it
in the 60s or women's suffrage right
these are things where that boxer
started because there's free speech in
another country you might not have ever
been able to argue for gay rights or for
civil rights or whatever in the first
place because it wasn't popular back
then interracial marriage four percent
of the country was in favor of it in
1958. that's a dramatically unpopular
position that would have been censored
it was people found it offensive
Classical liberalism so what's going on
in a place like Iran right now it's like
there's no Avenue for people no they
will kill you if you say it so but you
couldn't do that here so what happened
the gay rights activists they put their
ideas in the ring and guess what that
idea had truth on its side it had it had
righteousness on its side and so it
started beating everyone and before you
know it that's the heavyweight champion
of the world and we have gay marriage
right and you have totally you know you
know interracial marriage now went from
four percent approval to like six
percent disapproval so those are things
with the i the boxer got in the ring
crushed now what does
um social justice fundamentalism do is
it doesn't do that it doesn't box what
it says is anyone who tries to box
here's our champion boxer
which hasn't actually beaten anyone if
anyone tries to punch this boxer they're
gonna lose their job they're we're
Banning boxing well they're you said
what you're saying is like they're
racist or they're like like anyone who
wants to fight our ideas you put your
idea in the ring against ours we're
going to not just punish your idea we're
going to punish you we're gonna we're
gonna punish you for the argument so
again it's it's a huge difference
between we're gonna attack your idea
which is great now good attack the idea
tell me why it's wrong
no no we're going to punish you for
saying it boom that's the exact opposite
that silences all the debates so that's
it's illiberal to punish someone for
holding an idea it's the direct opposite
opposition so again this is we get the
semantics get confused cancel culture
is
the opposite of liberalism in that it
instead of using persuasion it wants to
shut down any attempt to persuade it
wants to shut it wants to punish the
person for trying to persuade criticism
culture which you could say is very
liberal which is no idea is sacred you
put your idea and I'm going to try to
show you why it's wrong that enhances
our group intelligence and it moves the
country forward and it allows the boxing
to happen and lets the lets the ideas go
out of the ring so we can see what the
truth is right and we can see who
actually wins in the ring when you see
so there's it when you see someone
criticizing ideas they're actually being
a classic liberal being a great liberal
regardless of what what their ideas are
and when you see someone trying to
punish the person they're being the
opposite and they're they're chilling
discussion they're making us less
intelligent as a uh Society oh yeah so
when I was a debater in high school uh
one of the things you were never meant
to do because it meant you were a
terrible debater was ad hominem attacks
which is like hey you know well like I
think you're a jackass or I'm a why am I
even talking about social justice right
that's that's what I've heard from
people you know that that's at him
that's ad hominem that's it's regardless
of what I said ignore your idea we're
gonna we're gonna discredit the idea
based on who said it that is not
for persuasion that's not boxing that's
that's just saying oh this I this boxer
was sponsored by that person so it's an
automatic loss
the forward tour is coming to a city
near you that means I'm coming to a city
near you I'm heading to San Francisco
Los Angeles Seattle Raleigh Denver and
more in the spring go to fordparty.com
to check out the upcoming dates or just
check out my social media primarily
Twitter unfortunately see you soon
[Music]
so in the book you use these figures to
illustrate various points of view and
one point of view I thought was really
um well expressed because I've heard it
too is like okay look guys like uh
you're really stressing me out
this uh and sure you know maybe wokeness
isn't
um you know right on everything but is
it really like that big a problem yeah I
I'd like to think of I have this
this concept of like three Obama voters
in 2012 of which I was one and a lot of
people I know and we all kind of agreed
on on we were pretty politically aligned
um we were pro-game marriage we didn't
you know we didn't like the right and
um you know we we we thought religious
Christianity was backward
um you know at least in politics
and and not necessarily it's great that
to be all aligned but that's what was
happening now today you take those three
people and they are totally at odds and
I say there's kind of that that group of
Obama voters in 2012 has now fractured
into three what I would think of as
three groups and one group is super woke
right they think that that what what I
would call wokeness is today's version
of the civil rights movement and it's if
you want to be on the right side of
History this is what you believe it's
passionate social justice then there's
the other another group which is which
I'm part of which says actually I think
this is the opposite of true I think
that wokeness is regressive I think that
it's fundamentally opposed and in
conflict with liberal social justice
movements
um and then and and then there's this
big third group that I think we need
almost you know we need to identify
because it's the biggest group and that
group says
uh they're not woke they think wokeness
is over the top but they think it's
in a there's it's still part of the the
good side it's still that that you know
wokeness is
um you know you you sometimes need the
progressive movements the pendulum
swings a little over you know over the
top and then it comes back and that's
what's all that's happening and this is
passionate extrasocial Justice and it's
yeah it's over the top but the anti-work
people are a lot have lost their minds
and and and they would look at A Book
Like Mine uh
why are you focusing so much on this
thing there's so many bigger problems
like
um and I fundamentally disagree with
that group and and I and I understand it
I think I probably would have agreed
with that group you know six years ago
and the thing I'd
um what what I think wokeness represents
is you know if you have a liberal
democracy is kind of this complex system
of
gears and springs and it's this kind of
fragile but kind of
complex thing wokeness is a force that
is actually it's it it is it's like a
simplifying thing yeah and you know it
also is trying to it actually
fundamentally tries to break uh the
system it tries to break it and and Maga
I would say the same thing these are
things that are
um in direct conflict with the general
system working well right you know um
denying the election you know and
undermining that that kind of faith in
the electoral process is is damaging to
like the foundation and I would say
cancel culture
um is damaging to the one of the most
important mechanisms which is kind of a
culture of free speech
and so
the reason I think that this is
something that is a serious threat is
not that it's necessarily that weakness
itself is so bad it's the fact that a
demagogue president is succeeding right
now to the degree that he is the fact
that a movement which is a demagogue
movement you know what's a demagogue
movement it's the same thing it's they
they preys on people's kind of worst
instincts and it's and it um it it
doesn't have any concern with the truth
and it bullies and it kind of acts like
the mafia um the fact that a movement is
succeeding to the extent that it is says
something about the broader liberal
immune system
that it's not working that something is
off and so it's really worth focusing on
I think yeah so so I think these are
very very helpful framework you've
provided so you have high wrong and low
rung I think most people can very easily
identify okay on the right the the low
rung has uh now assumed is Mega Energy
and Persona and their election deniers
and bunch of other things and it's it's
a very corrosive threat which I agree
with uh and then there I also agree with
the fact that there's now like a low
rung version on the other side
um and it's not super interested in you
know having reasonable discussions on on
some grounds
um but why should we be concerned about
it to the degree that you're describing
so one is look this is intrinsically
illiberal in that like they're they're
not sitting down and having uh like
conversation contest of ideas there like
attacking their bullying they're
canceling some people might look at that
and say like okay so some uh you know
professors like are like aren't saying
what they want or you know some
organization but like is is this really
I remember when I say that out loud it
sounds pretty bad because
by the way like I I agree with you that
the the
ideological excess is on this side uh
have very very
um uh profound repercussions and you
know you're right to be concerned by I
just want to try and
um like Point paint a picture for people
like why should the average American
who's like look this stuff's over the
top yes but it's coming from a good
place and it's like generally on the
right side like why should they be
joining you in the very concerned Camp
well I think you know I talk about the
immune system of the whole country the
whole society but each institution in it
you know that what the the the
foundation of a liberal democracy is its
institutions right it's institutions for
making knowledge for disseminating
knowledge for producing uh you know the
the companies the tech sector the
um you know the ACLU these these kind of
core things they each have their own
immune system each company has its own
immune system kind of you know when I
say immune system it's it's that the
company says this is what we do this is
our Telos which is kind of the
philosophical term for the end you know
the the Telos of a knife is to cut right
the the Telos of this you know of of of
a knock uh of a college Harvard says
Veritas on their plaque right I walked
by it a thousand times in in college it
says Veritas truth that is there you
know the tilos of a church is to serve
Christ so you're going to see the cross
everywhere you're going to see Veritas
everywhere around Harvard because that's
their cross right with their truth and
so what does the immune system have to
do there the immune system has to
protect that there's always going to be
other people with other motives who they
want to that that are going to be in
conflict with truth and what if it has a
strong immune system it'll say well
that's not how we do things here truth
comes first now what social justice
fundamentalism which kind of originated
in colleges has had the has managed to
do when their ideology comes into
conflict with truth so maybe there's
academic research that doesn't look good
for what they're they're saying you know
or or maybe there's
um a conservative speaker that wants to
come to campus what sjf which is what I
call it sjf they don't say let's go
debate that speaker they say let's let's
disinvite the speaker let's get that
let's shout in the in the actual session
so that no one can hear the speaker
right which is again that's very
different than debating the speaker
that's saying we want to uh not let
anyone else hear this speaker no forget
I don't want to go I'm not going to
change my mind no no one else here is
going to change her no one else is going
to hear that's bullying that's
authoritarian right
fundamentally opposed to Veritas which
is Veritas doesn't have as agnostic with
the actual thing says bring the speaker
bring all the speakers debate them if
this if a speaker comes with terrible
ideas those embarrass those ideas by
writing about how bad it is bring
another speaker whatever and so you see
a conflict here sjf has a certain way
and then Veritas as another what's scary
is that sjf has been winning
so the Telos is supposed to be Veritas
well well the incentive for the
individual
administrator and you talk about this in
the book or the professor or whatever
it's like hey I'm living my life I'm an
administrator I'm a professor uh and
then let's say students are really upset
about a certain speaker getting invited
it's a lot easier to be like okay like
you know like so much easier it's so
much easier for the company and the the
college to just go with the flow and not
get the mob angry at them and that is
when you scale that up you have mass
scale cowardice and mass scale uh
corruption because what's the opposite
of Integrity is corruption and
Corruption to me is when someone says
here's our Telos that's their
advertisement here's what you're paying
for here's what you're getting and
actually something else has become has
has superseded it so now actually when
this Telos comes into the sacred value
Veritas comes into conflict with
something else the other thing is
winning that's a corrupt institution so
you know we think of corruption as
politics and money but that's okay the
politician is supposed to serve their
District or whatever and and actually
they're taking money so they're not
doing that right that's just that's just
one form of corruption anytime someone
says this is our sacred value this is
what I do and actually they're secretly
doing this that's corruption so what
you're having here is when it's easy so
what you're saying is this is corruptive
to institutional Integrity oh yeah so so
sjf social justice fundamentalism
what it does is its goal is not to play
nicely to enter the marketplace of ideas
and try to persuade its goal is to take
over and actually stop the marketplace
from happening that's at colleges you
also go to companies and the company
says we do this media organizations
media media says we we want to get to
the truth also right that's Veritas is
supposed to be what the media cares
about you know let's investigate and
actually social justice fundamentalism
has come in and says we will fire the
op-ed the head of op-eds if they publish
an op-ed by this person we don't like
which is the opposite of what the
institution's supposed to do
um the ACLU I you know he's an example
as opposed to what are they supposed to
do they're supposed to defend civil
liberties regardless of where it is in
the Spectrum free speech is like their
sacred cow but actually all the free
speech language has gone out of their
documentation and they've actually you
know there were some Elite documents
internal where they've admitted to
basically saying we're only going to
take John take on Free Speech cases that
kind of jive with Progressive politics
that's social justice fundamentals and
coming in and actually conquering
hijacking the institution it's old Telos
goes out there so if you look at this an
institution after institution company
after company this one group has managed
to
come in instead of persuading anyone use
coercion and an authoritarian tactics to
actually hijack the institution and make
and change the the core Telos from what
it was
you know one thing that pains me deeply
and there's a story on The Intercept
about this a number of months ago but a
very significant proportion of uh
left uh leaning or Progressive
non-profits have become consumed by
internal strife around the fact that
like a particular leader uh you know
said something objectionable has some
practice that that indicated that they
weren't woke enough
um and I think there were these various
non-profit leaders saying like I spend
now a majority of my time
um trying to quell internal strife and
dissent as opposed to whatever the goal
of my organization is so the goal of my
organization could be I don't know
women's Reproductive Rights but instead
of going out there and helping make that
happen instead where we're now just
Naval gazing you know but so what's
happening there the leader is what
they're saying is
this is what we're supposed to be doing
this this thing right
and the leader is lamenting because they
want to be doing this yeah now if the
leader of the company
can't get what they want what does that
mean it means they're not really the
leader anymore it means that actually a
group within the company or a movement
outside the company has more power at
the company than the CEO that's happened
all over the place where if the CEO
truly had power they could say no we do
this
okay we'll do a little bit of you know
this other kind of activism maybe but
most of what we do is this or maybe we
don't do any of this other kind of
activism here they have the right to say
that you know
um but we we do this you know that's
sorry that's what we do here if they
can't say that without losing their job
or having their just reputation
destroyed it means that the power has
not in their hands anymore which is
scary that's but you that's when
something else can hijack the company
hijack means you've taken over now you
know when you hijack a plane it's that
the pilot is not in charge anymore
that's why it's so scary this hijackers
are now driving the plane so this is
that's why people think I'm like when
someone makes this point they're making
like a right wing point it does I don't
care what the or the ideology is that is
hijacking institutions it can be right
it can be left it can be up down I don't
care what it is
if something is hijacking institutions
and getting away with it and everyone's
scared to defy it any liberal lowercase
L has to say no we don't do that here
right and so it's not about this is not
about the horizontal axis I don't care
what the actual beliefs of sjfr I don't
like that they are not following Live
and Let Live they're not playing by the
core liberal rules that have that
they're supposed to be at the base of
the country
you guys already know all about
expressvpn I've talked before about why
they are the go-to service for
protecting your online activity big Tech
should not be snooping on us and
profiting from what we do in our private
time expressvpn can also help access
content including thousands of Netflix
shows that might be available in another
Market you just beam in encrypted
surreptitiously and you can be a UK user
and all of a sudden all that fun BBC
content can be yours I could go on and
on about expressvpn it's a VPN that I
trust and I'm not surprised that CNET
wired and others are rated at number one
visit expressvpn.com yang right now and
get three extra months of their service
for free that's exp r e s s vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
foreign
[Music]
they weaken and corrupt institutions
they instill uh lack of Integrity I mean
those sound very what happens then
people then then the citizens lose trust
in the institution so it's almost all
the scientific journals are still
totally fine and non-corrupt but some of
them have been shown to publish really
shoddy stuff that shouldn't have been
published when it goes along with when
it when it confirms sjf ideology and
meanwhile other there's been a number of
many many dozens of retractions journals
who have never retracted a paper before
peer-reviewed pass through then there's
a protest because it offends sjf
sensibilities it it conflicts with their
dogma and it's been retracted so when P
those stories people hear that they
start to think okay trust the science
really means trust our ideology which I
don't think is true most of the time but
it's awful for trust and if you people
enough people you're giving people a
reason to actually not you know it used
to be that you know only crazy
conspiracy theorists like you know Rush
Limbaugh would always say in a show that
you know one of the four corners of
deception is you know the Four Corners
you know like Academia and media and
Science and whatever and that's
conspiracy theory and that's not true
and we don't want people believing that
Yep this movement is actually and and
the failure of these institutions to
stand up to the movement are actually
giving credence to that which is not
you know that trust is the is the
strength of the whole thing oh you know
one of the more again they're doing a
lot of things
um but one of the biggest problems is
that all media sources now are on one
team or another and you know you're just
getting that point of view which makes
people not trust the media anymore
you're hearing a new story you don't
know it's true that's like that's so bad
like that's very bad you it's you know
it's um and and you know you and if you
have first of all a lot of people that
don't trust any media and then you have
the people that do trust one side and
people do trust the other side well
what's interesting is that this is not
symmetrical where uh 69 of Democrats
have high Trust in Media uh among
Republicans it's 15 among Independents
it's somewhere between like which makes
sense because most uh most big media
brands are left-leaning yeah
um but but then but we but on the other
hand there's there's something that
actually is better about the left East
Coast system because at least it has a
large variety and you'll see you know to
the you know to the credit like the New
York Times for all its faults like they
publish
um conservative op-ed writers all the
time they they popularize then there's
one thing that like they published one
from a republican Center and then they
well that that was a really bad that was
that was James Bennett the who is the
head of op-eds published an op-ed from
Tom Cotton
um that was
making a point that 60 of the country at
that point agreed with which was that if
these riots after George Floyd and all
of that after if these riots the violent
protesters gets you know continue we
need to bring in the the troops right
controversial point for sure
um and what James Bennett said is I
don't agree with this point but if we
can't be a newspaper yeah I mean it's a
U.S senator and not exactly it's also
this person has real power don't you
want to know what he thinks yeah it's
like a real person and guess what not
only you know there was there a huge
apology at the top of the op-ed the next
day that says you know we shouldn't have
ever done this um James Bennett was
fired he had to go he had to leave and
his career was tanked so now what is
that message to all the other op-ed do
not publish anything yeah it takes no
more and this is no more remark a place
of ideas this is we were playing under
the rules of this I this one ideologies
Echo chamber is now hijacked the rules
here uh so it's the same story over and
over and um and and we need the New York
Times you know that's the thing is it's
not that I want these institutions to
burn to the ground we need the ACLU what
it used to do we you know we need
Harvard to be Harvard
um just like I want by the way I also
want conservatism to be conservatism you
know like I never thought I would get
like nostalgic for Reagan
um but it's like when people I grew up
thinking that conservatism was the
problem right where ring was the problem
no it's that that the lower are
depriving our country of conservatism
and we need high-run conservatism
Elevate politics uh so I I guess I'll
have the same question for you which is
uh how the heck do you reverse this
de-evolution or regression on on the
left is there where you can like you
know uh elevate
[Laughter]
Elevate uh the discussion on that side I
I think so look I think there's in
general two like two schools of
solutions one is the harder stuff that
you're working on which is like actually
changing change the primaries yeah
ranked Choice voting actual practical
like activism where my brain works yes
that is all your credit that is that is
the hard kind I also think there's this
there's this huge low-hanging fruit here
which is there's this silent exhausted
majority
um and on the left within the left
there's this there oh you know dude in
the left there's just like a lot of fear
right and so so a I think there's I
think there's a lot of people like me
who are concerned about this who are too
scared to say it then I think there's
another big group we talked about who
who don't who aren't seeing the full
story at least that's how I see it
they're not seeing they they don't see
the hijacking that's happening they
don't understand that that that this is
a bigger threat
and so that's why I say that there's
kind of the low-hanging fruit is a
two-part thing there's awareness
and there's courage so there's awareness
meaning that that I think that if people
if most people including again most
former Obama voting people
um saw these stories looked in what's
actually going on in these companies
they wouldn't like it so I I want to
build awareness about that right I want
people to see the story for what it is
and understand that and and awareness by
splitting social justice into two groups
because you want to throw the baby out
with the bathroom we need liberal social
justice this is the pride of the country
is the history of liberal social justice
movements um it's one reason why it's so
powerful they managed to you know like
complain yeah yeah exactly the the the
the tactic is if you disagree with us oh
you're the version of you're the people
who wanted segregation back in the 50s
in the 60s you know you're the anti-gay
rights people
um and people don't want to be that
right on the left that's the worst thing
you can be called so they so they'll be
quiet it's not true though so awareness
is getting the difference between
criticism culture and cancel culture
difference between social justice
fundamentalism and liberal social
justice and
and getting that and then the but then
all of that is no is is useless if it's
just in people's heads so courage to
start speaking out and yes you're
talking about some Senators that might
have a death threat I'm not talking
about people that are going to have
death threats I'm not talking about even
people that might lose their jobs just
the vast majority of people who if they
start speaking their mind like nothing
actually that bad will happen and
leaders leaders at companies leaders at
you know at in colleges to actually
start leading and being like because in
their head they're thinking this isn't
how we do things here but it's easier to
just put up the apology statement or
whatever and to say no I'm not going to
do that we're going to not be corrupt
here we're gonna stand up for what we
believe
well uh I hope people
um really internalize the framework you
provided I learned a lot uh about it I
love this High wrong low rung the second
dimension of politics uh trying to
preserve Classical liberalism which has
done a whole lot of good for a whole lot
of people so anyone
watching this or listening to this you
can follow Tim where
wait but why.com that's my that's where
I live and do check out his book uh
right now it's digital and audio so you
can listen to his his voice
in action but it's a phenomenal read if
you want to figure out what's our
problem
what what what the heck and you can tell
it's been a six year labor of love for
Tim uh no it never it never want to do a
big book on current events again my God
but yes I'm I'm I'm proud of their final
outcome all the more reason you have to
check this one out because it might be
the only one thanks so much Tim thank
you
[Music]